So I'm starting with the code we had before that works correctly, except for,
with this assumption that all months have 30 days. So the first step is going to
be to define the stub procedure daysInMonth that gives the number of days in a
month. But, for our stub procedure, we're just going to always return 30. And
I'm going to modify nextDay to call daysInMonth. That's pretty simple, but I
should start testing, and I'm going to write some code to do testing. We don't
want to have to keep typing the same test cases in the shell. We want to write
some code for testing. For the problem that's provided, there were some provided
test cases. I'm going to write my own starting now. And I'm going to make sure
that these test cases, we don't expect the correct results yet because I'm
testing with 30-day months. So, I'm going to test two dates that are the same.
It's a boundary case, it's a useful one to test. I'm going to test from one day
to the next, that should give us one day. And these are test cases for daysBetweendates.
I should really be writing some test cases for nextDay. The
reason for that is that, if they fail, well, it's going to be more easy to
understand what went wrong, rather than just writing all of my test cases for
daysBetweenDays. So let's try some nextDay test cases. Got one where the day
advances. Let's get one where the month advances. And I will use a month that
has 30 days. So it will be correct in 30 months, but will still be correct once
we fix this. And I'll use advancing the year. A few test cases, probably we
should have more. But let's try that. We should save, and let's run this, and
we'll run our test. And, something failed. Not too surprising, this happens.
Let's see what failed. And the failure is type error that I'm calling
daysInMonth Not passing in the right number of parameters. In fact, I passed in
0. I should have passed in both the year and the month. So this is one of the
reasons for writing things in stubs, we can find these kinds of errors quickly.
So let's try again, and now we're test passed, and our test case is using
restrictions. I'm going to be a little more careful and print something out when
the test finishes, because it's a little bit dangerous to have nothing to tell
when the test finished. Maybe we didn't get any output for some other reason.